plus d'une cinquantaine d'entreprises
ont envoyé leur candidature pour
participer au concours du printemps des
entrepreneurs au final seuls neuf ont
été sélectionnés parmi elles
l'entreprise my city express une
entreprise san siro l'oise dirigée par
sylvain gibbons si on pouvait gagner le
chèque on serait ravis mais je dirais
déjà avoir un réseau qu'on parle de nous
qu'on soit présent
là par exemple au moment sur l'interview
c'est quelque chose qui est très
importante pour nous donc lyn et 7,7 à
reconnaître et tester l'adhésion
inscrits dans la catégorie jeunes
pousses à fertiliser l'enjeu était de
taille
à la clé un chèque de dix mille euros et
pour les gagner il faut séduire le
public
cent mille euros virtuels tout et chaque
personne pour investir
ce qu'il veut sur l'entreprise sur
l'entreprise 2 sur l'entente 10,3 et
l'entreprise qui aura collecté le plus
de son virtuel repartira quand même avec
un chèque de dix mille euros
un vrai cette fois
finalement my city express est arrivée
troisième au concours
c'est une application versaillaise qui
l'emportent cycliques géolocalise des
activités de loisirs